[Music]
all of this kind of connects to this we
add it sound it's a silent movie
this chart shows all the movies directed
or produced by legendary director DW
Griffith in 1912 he was a Hollywood
Titan but most of his movies they were
about the same length around 15 minutes
with the exceptions topping out around a
half hour long now look at the run time
for 1915 s Birth of a Nation what
happened now
the reason movies changed from 15-minute
trifles to featured attractions can be
traced to one silent movie it changed
the game in a way that transformed all
movies but it wasn't invented in
Hollywood it came from about 6,000 miles
away
[Music]
this is a foot here you go
metric people early silent film
historians actually talk about these
movies in feet and it makes sense the
same way that measuring tape comes off
real movies
come on reels too one reel of film is a
thousand feet give or take that's 15
minutes or fewer depending on what
framerate you play it back in in the
early days of movies the 1900s almost
all movies were about a thousand feet
one reel 15 minutes or fewer
these short movies were usually screened
in variety shows for a smorgasbord of
short films you drop into a Nickelodeon
a lower-class theatre where you'd see a
bunch of movies for a nickel five cents
you'd see Laura Comstock's bag punching
dog followed by the trapeze disrobing
act followed by the first screen
adaptation of Frankenstein the whole
thing was 14 minutes long 975 feet in
America some of this was enforced by
East Coast movie Trust's that controlled
and licensed movie patents for film and
projection they preferred single and
double reel films but even renegade
filmmakers out in Hollywood kept movies
pretty sure and with some exceptions
so did filmmakers across Europe it was
just easier to transport and project one
reel films that chart from the beginning
it's not a chart of time but feet and
this right here is a thousand feet that
one reel cut off for the most part
movies were small until the Italians
thought bigger
Italian movies were becoming spectacles
in the 1900s they were breaking out of
the standard 15 minutes short and try
new things by being outside the American
system of high-powered movie Trust's one
film in particular was able to rewrite
the rules
that's 1913 s Quo Vadis an epic story of
Romans in the time of Nero to tell that
story the Italian filmmakers took two
whole hours not 15 minutes
it was 8,000 feet long to get people to
see it Quo Vadis 'as promoters needed to
invent a new business model instead of
trying to force the long movie into
those movie theaters playing a bunch of
one real shorts promoters rented out
classy concert halls for Quo Vadis alone
they did the same at the Astor Theatre
in New York in playing the mammoth photo
drama everywhere from Arkansas
to the future state of Hawaii to draw
crowds from Nickelodeon's into those big
halls to watch one really long thing
covetous needed to be special it used
real Roman locations thousands of extras
in the first big stunts like chariot
races where the actors rode real
chariots in gladiatorial battles with
big hits and realistic weapons the
posters sold the spectacle and sold-out
seats and people notice
in the years following the release of
Quo Vadis DW Griffith increased the
length of his own movies Quo Vadis and
other italian epics were proved that big
movies could work
Griffiths movies like Judith of Bethulia
crept in the feature film lengths 61
minutes whole four reels
he released Birth of a Nation in 1915 it
was sold as the mightiest spectacle ever
produced in a long one clocking in at 12
reels it had big stunts - like many big
battle scenes now this movie was so
controversial that people called it
racist
in 1915 I mean the KKK are the good guys
but despite that he brought the
spectacle of Quo Vadis
to hollywood the trust that wanted to
keep movies short were already failing
but the public's love of lawn movies
kind of finished the job Birth of a
Nation solidified single features as
something worth funding and paying for
and even though today we don't measure
movies in feet Quo Vadis is not a relic
[Music]
this chart shows average movie times for
the most popular 25 movies each year
from 1930 on this time here it's 2013 a
hundred years after the 120 minute Quo
Vadis came out the running time
121 point four minutes
[Music]
this edition of Almanac is all about big
changes to the movies that came from
outside Hollywood and there are a ton of
other business model changes like quo
vadis so let me know some of the ones
that you've heard about in the comments
however I want to just prove to you one
more time that quo vadis really was a
huge hit this is an ad for when ursus
through the bull a parody movie that was
made in response to covetous --is
enormous success
[Music]